yeah i mean
obesity in america 2016 we got 650
million people in america that are obese
it's a ridiculous number today like more
than ever before
but to wrap up here with this i'm going
back to one of the things you and i
talked about at the beginning with the
influence of farm big pharma
the national expenditure for cancer care
in 2018
was 151 billion dollars that's a big
number that's not a small number that's
a very very big number so
then the question becomes the following
is it a good thing
for the folks in business for us to
truly cure cancer
or is cancer a very big business
that creates a lot of jobs that maybe we
do have the cure but we don't want to
cure
or am i you know going a little too deep
in into the because
you kind of know where i'm going with
this i'm just asking you a question 151
billion
of your industry that's a lot of jobs
right there if we were to divide that
between how many people
uh at a hundred thousand dollar your
salary can we get at 150 billion i'll do
the math for you right now just to kind
of figure this number out
if we got 150 billion 100 000
that's 1.5 million jobs at a hundred
thousand dollars if we were to cure
cancer we lose 150 000
100 000 year jobs is it 150 000 or is it
one point million 1.5 million
it's a lot of job 1.5 million hundred
thousand dollar jobs
so do we really are there people that
really are kind of like well we kind of
can do something to get rid of it but
should we really i don't know let's kind
of keep it around a little bit
what are your thoughts on that i think
people are trying to get rid of it first
they'll never get rid of it
because it's actually a part of
ourselves
that is it's impossible to eradicate
cancer
risk completely because it's the part of
the way that we do life right
these cancers are actually they're
perversions of our own
cells so we can't actually get rid of it
it's it's it's
it's uh impossible
yeah it's impossible to completely get
rid of it you can you can lower your
risk in many different ways but you
can't ever get rid of it completely
now i think that there's so much cancer
that nobody's thinking that we shouldn't
try to get rid of it
but what they've done instead which is
rather
uh despicable i think but
what they've done instead is that
they've raised the prices of these drugs
so incredibly high that a single course
will be
like you know these new drugs so so i'll
tell you the old drugs would have cost
you like you know
if you had to buy it and didn't have
insurance a couple thousand dollars
perhaps right
so when gleevec which is one of the big
breakthroughs of
the genetic era it was probably like
two thousand three thousand dollars for
a year for one patient
now you're talking about two hundred
thousand
three hundred thousand dollars that's
the price of a course of these
medications wait
wait let me stop you there so you you
said it used to be two thousand dollars
per year per patient
now it's two hundred thousand per year
these are different drugs yeah but
to to give you a sense of that in 2000
that was sort of the
best cancer drug you had and be about 2
000 3000. that was a lot back then so
normal
you know blood pressure drugs would be
like 80 bucks right so 200
300 400 is expensive 2000 was like wow
that's really expensive but the drug was
great
so if you were to get a sort of
state-of-the-art drug not that drug but
a different
state-of-the-art drug today most of the
price tags are a hundred two hundred
thousand dollars
it's insane like it's insane so what
they've done of course is instead of
saying okay let's get rid of cancer
they're like
well each cancer case instead of
bringing in two thousand bucks we'll
bring in two hundred thousand bucks
right a hundred times the cost
now as i'm saying that those are two
different drugs one is like a biologic
and stuff
and it's newer but at the same time that
is sort of state-of-the-art
drug at that time so it's really a huge
hot button issue because people are
saying like even if you can develop
these drugs nobody can afford them so in
the end it's the same
like you're not doing anybody any good
because you're pricing them so high
and the problem is that the price of the
drug has nothing to do with how
much it costs to make so um
you know for example there's a drug that
they make in india
you know it's a tablet this is you know
here they'll charge like
you know to 800 bucks and then in brazil
they'll sell it for like seven cents or
something like that is you know the
the price of the drug has nothing to do
with how how much it costs to make
only how much you're willing to pay
that's about it that's the only thing
constraining the price
that that that uh when you said 100 to
200 000 how much does that actually cost
them to make
the treatment yeah it's very little it's
all the all the research that goes into
it
but even then it's it's not
uh to measure it with the the cost of
the research because the marketing
costs like are higher than research
budgets like marketing budgets
more than they put into like why don't
you put the money into making good drugs
instead of marketing right because
somebody's got to pay for all the
doctors free meals and they've got to
pay for those 1500 bucks and they've got
to pay for all the
the university professors you've bought
out and all this you've got to pay for
those studies that prove that you're
good
it's it's a difficult system
you